後にウィークだけじゃないですか
ただいとかを足なしでやるってなると
この何だろうな
後輩筋の使い方
どうしたらそこの状態でぶら下がられるかっていうのを考えるって
30ペンってぶら下がってるだけだと
持てないものもちょっと肩上げて
力に入れるところを考えるとできるとか
結構面白いなと思って
さらにここからこういう動きでキャンプをしなきゃいけないと思ったら
下半身の振りとか
どういうタイミングで
どのポジションでいけばそれいけるかっていうのを考えると
キャンパスボードじゃなくて
普通のキャンパをすると
神経系の話とかでもなくて
動きが分かってくる
きっかけになる
他の家庭にやってるってところに生きてくる
キャンパスが大事
キャンパスもなんか
ペペペってやる
足ブランブラン
じゃなくて
ちゃんと体、腹筋だと体幹固めて
ゆっくり
ゆっくりというか
なんだろう
しっかり取りに行くというか
しっかりキャンパスする
キャンパスする
そういうのを結構意識してるってね
最近はやるんだ
やるんだ
取りやすいのばっかでやるんだ
そんなそんな
お疲れ様です
たとえば
普通に
1、2、3とか
3、2、1とかね
さっきの
3級の
はいはいはい
ゴールマイとかも
マークと体を入れて固めて
やれば
街で生きるんで
そっか
結構面白いですよ
シングね
顔がいいのか
普通のあっちのキャンパスボードやってもいいと思うんですけど
なんか
実践的じゃない
あー
うん、確かに
同じ動きだもんね
基礎体力作るんだったら
アリなんですけど
はいはい
あれもちょっとこう
なんだろうな
視点に入る
体の
使い方
筋力のトレーニングじゃないやつって
体の使い方のトレーニングかな
はいはいはい
お疲れ様です
いやちょっと
疲れ様です
疲れ様ですけど
大学の先輩なんて
大学の先輩で
もともと
でなぜか今
デザイン部にまた
ね
通ってるっていうんで
大学4年で
4年で。
じゃあ課題か何か。
卒業制作。
インタビュー的なことしてるんですけど。
すげえ恥ずかしいんですけど。
みんなの前で。
クライミングローン。
情熱クライミングローン。
めっちゃ語ってくれ。
シロトロフェストもある。
それまだ早い。
今ロックオンさせてもらってて。
でも動画撮ったけど。
インタビュー受けてくれるんでしょうか。
いや無理です。
みんな受けてくれるから。
むしろインタビューのライン角度。
えぇそういうの。
じゃあやってもらえばいいじゃないですか。
ナイスさんみたいな。
語れるものの漢字を持ってない。
それはでも引き出し方次第ですから。
そっちの腕が。
目的でしかない。
ダイエットも不思議。
その観点もいいじゃないですか。
うん、確かに。
体健康維持というか。
僕もそこ共通なんで。
それはいいですよね。
人と話せるし。
メンタルにもいい気がする。
ただ一人で気が消えたら、
みんな違う理由でフライミックしてると思うので。
やっぱそう。
そこもそうじゃないですか。
お互いは嬉しいですよね。
何を終わる。
仕事は。
そうですね。
死にられるから。
お客さんでね。
はい。
お疲れ様です。
彼にプラグ。
チェックから入れる。
前が20人もないですか。
ありがとうございます。
恋人に。
友達にみんなと話してたら。
ライミングをやりなさいって言われたって言って。
あ、それ。
来た人が行って。
それで初めて。
そういうきっかけで。
いや、部分はね。
本当に。
私とも忘れたなと思って。
あれ、この方。
だいたいの問題は。
フライミングを解決してく。
これ誰の言葉ですか?
え、誰なんだろう。
これ誰が言った言葉。
誰の言葉。
あるんですか。
合うのかな。
ナミスケア考えたわけじゃないと思う。
君さ。
それ前の。
え。
その前のお母さん。
ああ、そう。
ああ。
だって、それ。
ここに来てすぐぐらいから。
ある。
ああ。
あ、これ印刷ですか。
こういう。
そうそう。
DMみたいな。
ええ。
いいですか。
解決してくれる。
そうそうそう。
問題。
確かに。
今も問題解決してくれるかもしれない。
それぐらい。
それの。
白黒。
モノ黒みたいなの。
最初。
で、実家にありました。
ええ。
で、それ書いてあってきました。
だいたいのこと。
解決してくれました。
どうですか。
クライミングで解決できることはだいたい解決するようだと思いますけど。
クライミングで解決。
それ、あの。
えっと。
見方機部の。
あの。
YouTubeの動画があるんですけど。
はいはい。
さっき聞きました。
で、バックの音楽でそれが入ってるんですよ。
うん。
その。
作れるっていう音楽が入ってるんですよ。
音楽が入ってるんですよ。
うん。
で、最初すごい記者だったんですよ。
で、自分が。
これ誰が作ったんですかっていう話をしたら。
はい。
その後からこう大きい。
こういうのを作ってくれる人が。
ええ。
そういう風に。
あ、こんにちは。
こんにちは。
歌が誰が作ったんですか?
スタッフに。
あの。
YouTubeを制作してる人がいて。
あー、そういう。
はい。
これを見て。
うん。
いい感じの音楽が。
ええ。
顔を見せてくれたら。
え、聞いてます。
チャンネルはさっきしていったんで。 アイト君の顔に似てたりする。
アイト君お世話になってますよ。 イザカYouTube。
お世話になってます。 お世話してるの?
最強の音楽がよく聞こえてます。
前のやつは、僕たちの音楽をした方がいいみたいな話をして、 映ってましたよね。
すげー。 聞いてくれてる人がいるんだけど。
気づいた人がいる。
いいですよ。
文字があったかいな。
文字があったかいな。 うん、と思う。